[موسيقى]
مراكز الحضريه الحقيقه في الجزيره العربيه
كثيره جدا متعدده يعني اذا اخذنا مثلا
معظم مدن وعواصم جنوب الجزيره العربيه
اييه ثم نعرج الى منطقه نجران ثم تدخل الى
وسط الجزيره العربيه نجد الفاو ونجد
الافلاج والخارج في وسط الجزء العربيه ثم
ننتقل الى الشمال الى عديده جدا
منطقه جبه في حائل ادواته اللي دومه
الجندل تيما همم
والعلا وديدان في غرب المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
وذلك في شرقها نجد ايضا همم ساج وغيرها من
المواقع اللي تعود الى الفتره العبيد الى
الفتره دلمون
[موسيقى]
كل الجزيره العربيه احتكا ثقافيا وتجاريا
وحضاريا مع الحضارات الموجوده في بلاد
الرافدين مع حضرات الموجوده في سوريا
الكبرى سوريا الكبرى اللي هي من سوريا
الحاليه الى لبنان مع الحضارات في مصر
حتى وصلت الى الحضاره الرومانيه
الاسلام
بعد الميلاد ايضا احتكا بها العرب
واستفادوا منها